the next Call of Duty has been tazed
plenty this weekend beginning with an
update to the new town map in call of
duty black ops 3 which ran on a 24-7
playlist on weekend it's business as
usual for most of the match but at the
end a massive ship appears in the sky
the level blows up and the phrase
nuketown offline appears a clip of this
appeared on a live stream from youtuber
swifter and NBA player karl-anthony
towns her boat seemed to have been
briefed on the announcement rumors have
indicated that this year's card will be
called infinite warfare since it's in
development at infinity ward I think we
can determine that someone is super fond
of their own name that wasn't the last
of it though as Activision has since
officially trademarked call of duty
infinite warfare and celebrities
including Red Sox pitcher David Price
and the band we came as romans have
tweeted out pictures of themselves with
t-shirts that say enlist and I w7
respectively the logo on the shirt is
the same as the one that appeared in the
black ops 3 easter egg from the day
before if that's all a bit cryptic for
you both tweets feature a card at 2016
hashtag so not much guesswork from
marcia activision follow that up by
posting a cryptic video entitled know
your enemy which features a creepy dude
monologuing about being the architect of
your pain and claiming to be from the
settlement defense front an awfully
similar looking dude was discovered in
black ops 3 snoop town map this weekend
if that isn't enough for you Activision
posted yet another teaser trailer which
appears to be a sort of response to the
bad dude from the first trailer it asks
you to message a new page and facebook
called Cod messenger according to call
Julie site Charlie Intel if you do so
you'll be presented with the sort of
puzzle and solving it reveals that an
announcement is that land on me too at
nine
PST just a little while ago Infinity
Ward took to Twitter to officially
confirmed that the new college ed title
will be revealed tomorrow at ten-thirty
a.m. PDT during a live stream which you
can check out on twitch.tv for flash
ecology let me know what you think about
all this card news down in that comment
box and we'll be sure to update you on
activision's announcement tomorrow so be
sure to check back to gamespot